what's up guys the world has gotten its
first taste of the brand-new Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles movie the trailer
dropped this morning and we got a sneak
peek at it yesterday with one of the
screenwriters of the film let's break it
down we have a cool panel to do it first
he is known as the black nerd our good
friend Andre Meadows cowabunga and our
old pal the creator of honest trailers
Andy signor radical all right we all saw
this trailer give me your first thoughts
this definitely calmed some of my nerves
I would give it that is a different take
on the turtles as we've been hearing up
to this point but it was good to
actually see them in action I think up
to this point we've had descriptions
we've had leaked pictures we've had
everything except the actual turtles in
the actual movie doing their thing so I
will I'm happy to actually see them move
now my first instant was like it is a
Transformers movie but I say that with
the best parts of what a transfer movie
is like because to me my biggest problem
transform movies is they don't have the
personality that the Ninja Turtles have
and I sense in this one it's a way from
Michael bata from afar give us a
Transformers the action movie but with
the personality of the Turtles
I probably I think a lot of the internet
may be worried but I'm cautiously
optimistic as far as their personalities
it's hard to tell right now because we
didn't really get a lot of their
personalities in this TV this is a very
much 88 City and his perform it's just a
mask see don't pick up right the
direction I am interested because I was
were like are they gonna go with this
weird gritty Christopher Nolan II type
of anything and I feel like I don't
really want to see their like even
though the original comics are
definitely darker and more violent like
I'm a kid of the show and looking back
on the show it's not a great it was fun
when I was pleasantly surprised by the
screenwriter I even asked him I'm like
is there gonna be like a tumblr version
of the turtle van and he's like no so I
go thank God we know there's been a lot
of back and forth on the internet about
this movie what are the major points
that are really gonna set people off
there were a couple of changes yes
origin stories difference so that's the
big controversy monster no fans is the
origin story
there's a line that said by William
Fichtner who plays shredder in this that
essentially a loser the fact that he and
April nails father somehow are involved
with the mutagen that then makes the
turtles but heroes are not born they're
created that's what your father and I
were trying to do I mean every iteration
of turtles has had a different way I
mean we've had mutagen just beyond earth
we've had mutant comfort dimension x
it's a movie right it's like the cartoon
the the vial falls in the sewer and they
become what it is it's like I didn't
mind as a kid but when you're making a
movie I could see you want some sort of
fun reveal and the characters to be
intertwine so I mean I haven't seen the
movie I have into the movie but I'm
gonna give the writers credit of like
trying to be it more invested to the
backstory to create more it holds that
potential yeah and the SCOOTER I said
some interesting when we talk to him
like he's like you guys all know the
story like why do you want to go to
movie and see the same story you already
know yeah that reminds me we actually
had the chance to talk with one of the
writers of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles movie let's take a look at our
exclusive chat with screenwriter Andre
Nemec as you were figuring out how do I
go about this story what were some of
the core elements are themes you wanted
to approach you know one of the core
components of that always seems to boil
back down to the fact that you're
watching a story of brothers and you're
watching a story of teenagers who are
sort of coming into their own learning
who they are dealing with the defiance
factors that sort of all teenagers deal
with in terms of relating to their
parents in this particular case it's
Master Splinter for them and if you
really watch them closely over the years
what you're really watching is you're
watching sort of four parts of a
singular personality that are making
decisions in any given moment as to
whether to go left or to go right and it
was a lot of fun to sort of play in that
sandbox and be able to to be able to
write for those guys and as far as
writing the action sequences did you
have any other influences um you know at
times when you were sitting down and
you're trying to compose these action
sequences some of the fun of that is you
know busting out the toys and playing
with the turtles and moving them around
on your desk and sort of really creating
you know you sort of harken back to your
days when as a kid you were doing that I
know a lot of people want to know will
there be a war
or a rhinoceros appearing in the film
perhaps Andre thank you for inviting us
here today and I'm so excited for the
movie thanks for your time thank you
okay so granted the teaser trailer super
short what are the some of the biggest
questions that loom in your mind um I'm
big I'm curious about this whole
shredder thing I'm cute because this is
not a Roku Saki we try to ask if Oroku
Saki is anywhere mentioned we got a
perhaps perhaps not you know like so I'm
really curious about how this shredder
is working is it is did he get this suit
is the suit itself something special is
the mutagen gonna be involved there's a
lot of big questions around that yeah I
mean my big hope is that they build a
universe out of this because I think as
a kid I loved collecting the figures and
like checking off on the back of the box
like I need this one I don't have this
one like it was about selling toys at
khartoum but they were building these
fun characters and they were colorful
and fun and I think that's something
that I hope they really do do and and we
asked like are there gonna be Easter
eggs like other after credits moments
yeah he smiled and like there's stuff to
keep your eyes peeled but it's like the
idea of even Dimension X as like if they
tease that at the end and Krang does
come back and like for part 2 like
there's a huge world there that they
give so much fun in and create it from
from seeing various variations of
Turtles 280 series of to thousands of
cartoon series of comics the the new
series I could see elements of all those
in this movie in some form of fashion
where there's an inspiration or a direct
take or whatever so it seems like they
are creating a new thing while keeping a
lot of these elements the question is
will it all work together well be one of
those things where it's inspired by
everything to create this new thing or
is it so we got to put this in to make
these fans have got put this in to make
these fans happy that it ends up just
being nothing but a bunch of references
and all that kind of stuff and then
people just getting mad about whatever
so well if there's one thing for certain
people always find a way to get back
yeah especially internet yeah okay Andre
you are one of the foremost cartoon
minds and turtles fans in the universe
uh uh we want to test you on oh no I
actually root around and found all my
old toys Oh guys see this is
this is one mess-up Andy
whenever you're ready okay this is a
pizza face actually supposed to be in
the new series right here - but yes
pizza face next up all right
oh my gosh I know this I know this I
know this um
dirt bag yes okay oh that's a neutrino
which name oh gosh it's called Eck yes
this one's easy
okay ah yeah ice duck which he should
have his own series I don't want to put
that out there and then brown okay
Oh rayful a fugitoid mondo gecko because
of that we're giving you all of those so
what do you think of the trailer do you
think this movie's gonna be awesome are
you a little worried about it leave an
answer in the comments section below the
coolest answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank this awesome
panel Andre go ahead and plug your
YouTube channel yes my youtube channel
is black bear comedy I will be doing a
recap of the Turtles trailer as well
I've got a got a tune in for that and I
want to thank my pal Andy but hey follow
me on Twitter real yes Andy signor
follow this guy and hit me up on Twitter
we'll talk movies and whatnot thanks for
watching I'm how Rudnick bye bye
[Music]